welcome to the man of Recaps this is The
Walking Dead Daryl Dixon season 1 if you
haven't watched it yet don't spoil
yourself here click the link in the
description and sign up for AMC plus
binge through all of season 1 now at the
end of The Walking Dead our group
finally found long-term safety at their
new super group The Commonwealth but
Daryl Dixon didn't stick around he
hopped on his motorcycle and rode out to
explore the rest of the Zombie
Apocalypse Now Daryl's own Series starts
right off with him Shipwrecked and
washing ashore somehow he's made it all
the way to France so Daryl's off on a
French Adventure trying to find a back
home but the zombies here in France l f
the hungry ones are more dangerous than
Daryl's used to they got weird variants
like some of them are burning hot
zombies so Daryl makes some friends
luckily everyone in France speaks
English once some bad guys show up Daryl
helps fight him off but his new friends
knock him out and Rob him anyway but
Daryl's rescued by some new friends yes
they're nuns the main nun Isabelle gives
Daryl the tour and yeah that's the cool
thing about zombie apocalypse Europe you
got all these castles that were designed
to be self-sustaining before electricity
there's a kid living here lant who's a
real gentle soul and he and Daryl hit it
off cuz they both have long hair but
these nuns Believe laur's real special
the second coming the Messiah Daryl's
like yeah right good luck with that I'll
see you later crazy nuns but the bad
guys are investigating their lost Patrol
they're led by face tattoo guy Kon one
of the guys killed was his brother and
this girl blames it all on Daryl so Kon
and his men storm the nunnery Daryl's
got to help defend him although these
nuns are far from defenseless oh it's an
epic killer nun fight that's another
cool thing about France by the way they
don't have a lot of modern guns L around
so they're fighting with cool old timey
guns and medieval Weaponry now these
nuns are part of a larger good guy group
The Union of Hope and they want to get
laurant up to their base in the north
and apparently there's a port nearby
with working ships so mulio Daryl is
escorting lant and Isabelle on a cross
France Adventure along the way there's a
couple fun adventures like this group of
kids who grew up here in their preschool
they're fighting an American who's taken
over this castle and Daryl falls into
his zombie moat then there's a conductor
who's built himself a zombie Orchestra
all right that's new but soon they make
it to the big city welcome to Paris the
union of Hope Has a good base here led
by faloo and while theant is probably
not the real Messiah he is a nice kid
and gives them hope so to buy Daryl a
boat ticket home they go to paris's
hottest underground zombie apocalypse
nightclub the club's owner is this
English guy Quinn who also has long hair
in fact he looks exactly like Daryl if
he brushed it back and turns out Quinn
is Isabelle's ex-boyfriend yes she
wasn't always a nun before the zombie
apocalypse she was a bit of a party girl
and also a bit of a thief there's a real
cool episode where we follow Isabelle
the night the zombie apocalypse started
and as you imagine things got bad real
quick she and Quinn were heading out of
town they stopped to pick up Isabelle's
pregnant sister Quinn was like yo she's
slowing us down we got to ditch her but
Isel wasn't having that ditched him
instead they ended up at the convent but
unfortunately her sister died in child
birth but when her body reanimated as a
zombie she was able to finish giving
birth and that's laurant so it was a
miracle birth but now that Quinn meets
laurant he reveals a secret he is laur's
father he wants laurant and Isabelle to
join him and be a happy family but it's
like yo you cheated on me with my sister
then tried to ditch her in the zombie
apocalypse you're kind of a douche but
there's a bigger bad guy out there
Madame Jan who runs the super group that
Loosely controls all of France she
controls the port with the transatlantic
ships that darl Dixon rode in on and now
we finally get that story Daryl was
cruising around America on his
motorcycle he stopped to get gas from
this French scientist who was paying
fuel in exchange for rounding up live
Zombies by the way they had a radio here
so Daryl checked in with his best friend
Carol they had a bad connection but she
said someone came back who came back we
got to know Daryl befriended this kid
here but one of the other guys killed
him so Daryl picked a fight but there's
a strict no fighting policy here so
strict in fact that if you break it
you're loaded onto the ship to be zombie
meat but Daryl's not going out like that
eventually he escaped but whatever
experiments they're doing on these
zombies makes them fast and strong oh
Daryl's got to abandon ship so yeah it's
Jana who's really excited about these
experiments to make zombies stronger and
she's mad at the American Dixon who
ruined her ship so she sends her goons
to hunt him down theant got separated so
they meet up at the big Paris Landmark
the Eiffel Tower unfortunately even in
the zombie apocalypse it's real crowded
with tourists but now Jana has locked
down the city they need Quinn's help to
escape so Isabelle agrees to be his
girlfriend again in exchange for getting
darl and laurant out of the city but
Quinn already has a girlfriend who's
none too pleased he's swming over his ex
so she turns him into Jana and Daryl and
lant are caught so Jan learns how this
whole group thinks laurant is the
Messiah kid so she wants to control lant
and have him endorse her as president of
France and indeed tonight's her
inauguration party where the main event
is the American Daryl Dixon in a zombie
Gladiator battle but it's just one
zombie that's no big deal except they
shoot it with the special injector Dart
they soup it up with the zombie steroids
oh this one might be a problem but
Daryl's a pro he still takes this thing
out for round two they chain him and
Quinn together the long Duo vers four
super zombies these zombie steroids are
still a work in progress sometimes they
don't work at all and on this other one
it makes them so violent it attacks
another zombie working together Daryl
and Quinn take the other two zombies out
Daryl's like are you not entertained and
Chucks this zombie head right at Jana
now the resistance causes a distraction
so Daryl can try to escape Quinn was
injured though he's slowing him down and
now he wants to do right by Isabelle and
the rant so he has Daryl cut off his
hand so he can separate and buy him time
but then it's awkward when zombie Quinn
catches up to Isabelle Daryl gives Laur
the battle AXS god'll forgive you kid as
he kills his first zombie who is his
father and so it looks like they're out
of danger but danger catches up to him
it's cauldron he wants to kill Daryl and
avenge his brother but Jan's orders were
to kill laurant and the nuns too and
cauldron is a badass but a good guy so
he shoots the other goons instead mosio
Dixon I will see you later so our group
completes the journey to the nest which
turns out is the famous landmark m
Michelle so they're safe at the
headquarters of the Union of hope this
multi-religious peaceful group led by
this guy saying but of course Jan is
going to come for them eventually she
figured out KRON betrayed her so he's
imprisoned we'll see him later so Daryl
settles in for a bit peeling potatoes
Making Sexy Eyes with Isabelle yes these
two have a blossoming romance but
Daryl's not sticking around they found
him a boat back to America but he's
meeting the boat at the Normandy Beach
where there is the cemetery of American
soldiers who died here in World War II
including Daryl Dixon's grandfather it's
a touching moment as Daryl reflects on
history and how sometimes life takes you
far from home but that's where you need
to be so Daryl decides he can't go home
yet he's got to stay in France and see
this through meanwhile back in America
some random dude is on Daryl's bike and
he's chased down by Daryl's best friend
Carol she's like hey that's my friend's
bike where'd you get it but he doesn't
want to talk he tries to robber so she
knocks this guy out ties him up in the
trunk like hey let's try that again so
yes Carol is coming to find Daryl will
she make it all the way to France and
that's where the Walking Dead Daryl
Dixon season 1 comes to an end yes
season two is confirmed Daryl's
Adventure is just getting started
there's a link in the description where
you can sign up for AMC plus binge
through all of season 1 now I gave you
the quick recap but there's a lot of
great stuff I couldn't cover it's a cool
new setting in Zombie France full of
unique exciting new zombie encounters
will Daryl finally find love with
Isabelle what is Madame Jana's endgame
with the super zombie experiments and of
course Carol is joining the show can't
wait to see her back in Action so click
the link in the description and sign up
for AMC plus now join in for The Walking
Dead darl Dixon and the rest of the
expanded Walking Dead
Universe if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and
movies